perfectionism is the unreasonable and
self-defeating ambition of getting
something absolutely right - which makes
us difficult to be around and punishing
to live within. The origins of
perfectionism lie in the imagination.
In the ease with which we can conjure up a picture of an ideal state of affairs
compared with the monstrous difficulty
of bringing such a state into being by
ourselves. The sickness of perfectionism
just states in a fertile gap between our
noble visions and our mediocre reality
and yet our problems do not ultimately
arise just in our love of perfection.
They lie in our reckless tendencies to
under-budget for the difficulties of
achieving perfection. The proper target
for gentle criticism is premature
perfectionism. How accurately we budget
for time and effort is always dependent
on a proper grasp of the inherent
difficulty of any task. If we fully
recognize something to be exceptionally
difficult
we don't panic when our first efforts are
weak and progress slow. It's difficult
but we knew it would be. High standards
only become a problem when we think
something might and should be
substantially easier than it turns out
to be and when we read our struggles as
marks of our own ineptitude rather than
as an inevitable part of a legitimately
lengthy journey. Perfectionism is only a
problem because we have under-budgeted
for difficulty not because we are aiming
high. It strikes when we imagine we might
write a good novel in six months or have
a good career by the age of 30 or have
worked out spontaneously how to have a
successful marriage.
our perfectionism starts to torture us
when we lack information on how hard
others had to work and how much they had
to suffer before reaching their ideas of
perfection. In a better world culture
would endlessly draw to our attention
the first draft and hidden labors of
other people and properly alert us to
the true horrors exacted by anything
worth doing. We would not then be so
impatient and such sickly perfectionists.
We would be patient resilient Questers
for excellence. The problem isn't that
we're aiming for perfection. It's that we
don't have an accurately redemptive idea
of what perfection really demands. At the
School of Life we believe in developing
emotional intelligence to that end we've
also created a whole range of products
to support that growth find out more at
the link on the screen now